- [Voiceover] We're told the graph of y
equals two to the x is
shown below, alright.
Which of the following is the graph
of y equals two to the
negative x minus five?
So there's two changes here.
Instead of two to the x, we
have two to the negative x
and then, we're not leaving that alone,
we, then, subtract five.
So let's take 'em step by step.
So let's first think about what y
equals two to the negative
x would look like.
Well, any input we now put into an x,
we're now going to take the negative of.
So if I input a two, it's
like taking the opposite
of the two and then, inputting
that into two to the x.
And so, what we're essentially going to do
is flip this graph over the y-axis.
So, here we have the point two comma four.
Over here, we're going to have the point
negative two comma four.
When x is zero, they're going
to give us the same value.
So they're both going to
have the same y-intercept.
And so are graph is going to look like,
our graph is going to
look something like, this.
They're going to be mirror images
flipped around the y-axis.
So, it's going to look like that.
That is the graph of y is
equal to two to the negative x.
And then we have to worry about
the subtracting five from it.
Well, that's, you're subtracting five
from your final y-value
so that's going to work.
You're subtracting five
to get your y-value now,
where your y-value is
going to be five lower,
is I guess the best way to say it,
so this is going to shift
the graph down by five.
So instead of having
the y-intercept there,
it's going to be five lower.
One, two, one, each hash mark is two
so this is one, two, three, four, five,
is going to be right over there.
So shift down by five, two, four, five.
It's going to look like that.
And the asymptote,
instead of the asymptote,
going towards y equals zero, the asymptote
is going to be at y is
equal to negative five.
So the asymptote is going to
be y equals negative five.
So it should look something like,
something like what I
am drawing right now.
Something like, something like that.
So now we can look at which choices.
So this should be the graph of y
equals two to the negative x minus five.
So let's see which of
these choices depict that.
So this first choice
actually seems to be spot-on.
It's exactly what we drew.
Well, we can look at the
other ones, just in case.
Well, this is, this looks like,
what did they do over here?
Looks like they, instead of flipping over
the y-axis, they took the,
they flipped over the x-axis
and then they shifted
down, so that's not right.
Here it looks like they got what we got
but they flipped it over the x-axis.
And this looks like they
flipped it over the y-axis
but then they shifted,
instead of shifting down
by five, it looks like they
shifted to the left by five.
So we should feel pretty good especially
'cause we essentially drew this
before even looking at the choice.